colas mais aussi ikea ou encore le
français renault même dans des secteurs
épargnés par les sanctions des dizaines
de grandes marques ont décidé de quitter
le pays réponse de la russie vive le
patriotisme économique et un message
nous vous remplaceront affiché ici en
russe avec les logos des partants les
russes vont désormais boire du cool
colle à manger chez proust nightwatch
cas et rouler en lada granta
cette créatrice de mode elle s'est
convertie au made in russia contrainte
et forcée elle se fournissaient jusque
là dans le monde entier en tissu haut de
gamme
si j'avais besoin de matières premières
pour les manteaux alors c'était l'italie
ou l'angleterre
problèmes logistiques impossible de
faire des virements internationaux elle
a donc improvisé avec des tissus russe
un défi
le but de ce coton c'était d'absorber
correctement l'humidité parce que l'on
fabrique des torchons pour la cuisine
avec couronne vous comprenez c'est ya
maintenant ma mission ça va être de
l'alléger et de le rendre plus agréable
au toucher
mais certains produits sont tout
simplement introuvables en russie comme
une encre spéciale pour tetra pak il y a
donc des restrictions sur les emballages
ne reste que 30 % d'impression sur les
100 % habituels l'arrière reste
complètement blanc si on compare à que
design initial les changements sont très
visibles on est important que la marque
explique ce qu'il se passe
c'est dans les centres commerciaux que
l'absence des enseignes internationales
surtout dans l'habillement et la plus
visible depuis des mois des centaines de
magasins fermés